da ah that goes into our forecast and
and placing of inventory it's truly
amazing
we think of that as the brains in the
heart of our operations what we like to
refer to as the symphony of humans and
robots working together to deliver
customer orders Amazon really got going
in a big way with robotics in 2012 with
our acquisition of Kiva systems Kiva's
technology which we now call Amazon
robotics enabled a step function change
in how much inventory we could store in
a building but also making jobs easier
and safer as Jeff mentioned earlier
we're excited to share today that we
have now deployed over 200,000 robotic
drive units since 2012 but again it's a
symphony of humans and robots working
together and in that same time frame
we've added over three hundred thousand
full-time jobs the robotic drive units
aren't the only robotics we've been
deploying in our buildings I'll share a
couple examples of other systems we've
deployed and excited about the first is
our robotic pallet Iser the robotic
pallet Iser is an industrial robotic arm
that stacks yellow totes of inventory on
the pallets as Jenny mentioned placement
how do we get the inventory to the right
place this these these stacks of totes
are used to transit between our
facilities these robotic pallet eyes
errs have now lifted over 2 billion
pounds of totes again making jobs easier
and safer for our associates taxi he
really goes into everything we're
thinking about in robotics we were
excited to roll out last year our
robotic tech best which allows
associates to walk safely onto the
robotic floor confident that the drive
units will detect them and move out of
their way but
we can't stop here customer expectations
for convenience selection cost and
especially delivery speed continue to
increase and so we realized we needed
another step function change in robotics
this time in middle mile logistics
Amazon's middle mile network there's
really the backbone responsible for
connecting our more than 175 fulfillment
centers with the thousands of last mile
delivery nodes be them post offices our
own delivery stations the core of
effective middle mile logistics is
packaged sortation we sort billions of
packages a year and the challenge and
package sortation is how do you do it
quickly and accurately and in a world of
prime one-day accuracy is super
important if you drop a package off of
conveyor lose track of it for a few
hours or worse you miss sort it to the
wrong destination or even worse if you
drop it and damage the package in the
inventory inside we can't make that
customer promise anymore
just deeply disappointing to not only
our customers for ourselves and so we
needed something new we're also within
our middle mile Network there's a lot of
different scale of fan-out we need to in
some facilities sort to tens of
destinations and others hundreds of
destinations we needed a solution that
was going to scale to all that so I'm
excited today to announce for the first
time our new Pegasus drive sortation
system the Pegasus system uses the same
Amazon robotics technology but instead
of moving pods of inventory
it moves packages to sort destination
let me let me take you through a little
bit more how this works associate in
ducks a package onto the drive the drive
moves across the robotic field and and
then is ejected into a shoe
representing a sort destination we
collect all the packages at the bottom
that shoot destined for one destination
move it to a bound transportation
typically to a truck the we were able to
get this solution up and live and I'm
excited announced this is this is live
already these drive units have had
driven over two million miles and in
service of package sortation we were
able to get this up and running very
quickly due to our investment in
simulation through simulation we were
able to design test and evaluate the
safety of our induct stations for our
associates and do that combinatorial
optimization that Russell described to
efficiently route drives from the index
station to their destinations sore point
minimizing congestion on the floor
maximizing the throughput of the system
and the results are in this system just
works better already
this technology reduces miss sorts by
more than fifty percent over our
conventional sortation systems but in
developing this we also realized we had
an opportunity to rethink the way we
design robotic drives at Amazon so again
for the first time for the Romar's
audience I'd like to show you our new
xanthus drive the xanthus Drive is much
thinner profile 1/3 the number of parts
half the cost easier to maintain but
preserves all the safety features of our
existing drives including the ability to
detect the robotic tech
but what we're really excited about with
this is that we're gonna be able to use
it in multiple applications the first is
a exhort drive so by putting a conveyor
a packaged conveyance top on top of this
we'll be able to deploy this in our
Pegasus sortation systems the new ones
going live soon the we're also gonna be
able to use this for multiple different
robotic application
mobility applications throughout the
throughout our network but with our
recent acquisition of canvas
technologies we expect to be able to
combine this drive platform with the AI
and the autonomous mobility capabilities
the canvas technology provides and for
the first time allow the robots to move
outside of our robotic drive fields and
interact collaboratively with our
associates to do a number of mobility
tasks in our building I'm super excited
about everything we're doing in robotics
I could spend all day talking about it
but at this point I think I'm gonna hand
off to my friend Rohit Prasad we'll tell
you about what we're doing in Alexa AI